can we talk about
the torah
yes what is it and uh is it the literal
word of god
um easy questions yeah uh well
the torah is the five books of moses
written in hebrew um i
like most i think modern rabbis
non-orthodox or non-literalist rabbis
will tell you that it's a product of
human beings um
and i believe that they are
inspired by god but it's clear to me
that it's a human product and i think
that people who study modern biblical
criticism it's really hard to study
modern modern
criticism gives a wrong impression i
would say modern scholarship on the
bible and not appreciate the fact
that it it even has levels of language i
mean it's just like if you read today
um
somebody
writing like shakespeare you would say
this isn't it's it's like english is
developed it's different it's not the
english we speak today and if you study
the bible and you know hebrew well
enough you even see that this was
written over hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of years
um
it is a holy book and i like the idea
that it is what what you say in hebrew
is torah mayam and not to rami sinai
that is the torah is from heaven but
it's not from sinai
so it has its origin beyond us
but it has things in it that i think and
this is one of the
um one of the things that was
a huge controversy at my congregation
when i started to do same-sex marriages
there are some people who try to argue
that the the torah does not forbid them
whether it does or not it seems to me we
understand things that
were not understood in the ancient world
about gender and sexuality and so so you
think that
in the scripture in the words
you can find the kind of spirit that
supports the idea of gay marriage well
that's yes that's my my argument is that
you criticize the torah by the torah
that is it gives you
the understanding
that you use
to evaluate its own claims
and and i think that judaism by the way
has always done that because it's clear
that there are things in the torah that
the rabbis
changed altered grew expanded diminished
um i think that's what it is to be part
of a living tradition
yeah you wrote in your book why faith
matters
quote walt whitman wrote that in order
for there to be a great books there must
be great readers for a book to remain
powerful throughout generations it
cannot have a single meaning scripture
like great poetry is not reducible to
other words that is one cannot
paraphrase paraphrase it and capture the
totality of its meaning
so
how the heck do you capture the meaning
of the words in scripture
is it an ongoing process to the
centuries yes exactly so it's a
continual conversation
of
sages scholars readers
strugglers seekers
mystics visionaries all of them making a
contribution i mean
i write a weekly torah column for the
jerusalem post now
what is there left to say
but every week what i do is i start
opening books and seeing what people say
and it starts to percolate and you
realize that you're entering this
conversation that's been going on for
thousands of years with with remarkable
minds and it and
it's constantly fertile in new insights
so yes
that's what it is to be part of a
tradition yeah why do people keep uh
writing love poems you should have
figured it out
that's right by this point already i use
the analogy sometimes of diet books if
any diet worked there would be one book
there'd be one book and you'd be done
you